When I saw your face
I knew it was
A big race
To kiss you
You drive me crazy
Because I wish
You're the one
that was sleeping
Right next to me
Wow.
Wow, what is going on?
And I'll treat you right
Every single night
I'll massage your feet
You look so stunning
in that dress too.
Thank you.
Trying to make
my balls blue?
-This is not happening.
-You gotta stop it.
Come on, girl.
And here you are
Looking so
Beautiful,
like you always do…
I'm a little confused,
'cause from what I remember,
Patrick said
he wasn't going to make
any more moves on Georgia.
'Cause I wish I had
You cuddling me…
Damn, that kid's sneaky.
And I love you
Whoa, did he just drop
the L bomb?
Wow.
I know a girl
And her name is Lana
Dear Lana
You're so special
Just to me
Come like water, baby.